[Musique]
mignonne mac fois obtenue aux alentours
de deux heures du matin la création d'un
conseil des imams chargé de lait la
bêtise et il discutait avec les
dirigeants du conseil français du culte
musulman
il leur a donné 15 jours pour rédiger
une charte des valeurs républicaines
d'ici quatre ans le chef de l'état veut
mettre fin à la présence en france des
300 imams étrangers détaché par la
turquie le maroc et l'algérie
il faut sortir de cette mascarade est en
train de mettre toute l'économie à plat
tout simplement parce que le
gouvernement s'est complètement planté
réussir ce nouveau déconfinement enfin
c'est vous qui a employé le terme jeu là
que je sais que c'est un terme banni
maintenant 6 milliards d'euros c'est le
chiffre d'affaires du black friday l'an
dernier en france c'est dire l'enjeu
pour les commerçants alors faut-il
reporter cette opération de promotion
est ce que vraiment vendredi prochain
c'est la bonne date pour organiser un
black friday
ma réponse est non et j'espère qu'il le
comprendront aussi j'aurai l'occasion de
leur en parler pour leur demander de
faire preuve de sens des responsabilités
et examiner toutes les possibilités de
décaler cette opération qui n'a pas de
sens dans les circonstances actuelles s
qui le donnait là une position
personnelle ou est-ce que c'est aussi la
vôtre ce matin c'est une position
collective ce que nous nous disons c'est
qu organisé une opération promotionnelle
alors qu'on ne sait pas encore si on est
en capacité de rouvrir des commerces et
quand ça correspond pas exactement à ce
qu'on veut donc ça doit être possible
d'entendre à la fois les attentes des
français qui d'avoir des promotions les
attentes des commerçants qui veulent
dynamiser les ventes
en même temps que ce soit le 27 ça
paraît pas la meilleure idée
on peut discuter du black friday par le
principe mais pas huit jours avant je
pense que c'est pas raisonnable
il faut pas que cela soit un prétexte
pour nous dirons repouse le black friday
donc vous n'ouvrez pas le 27 fait
expliquer qu'on va décaler le black
friday est autant expliquer qu'on va
reporter noël au 14 juillet c'est une
une opération mondiale avec une grosse
opération de communication il faut que
les
les commerces soient en situation de le
faire ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'ils
rouvrent avant selon nos informations
carrefour accepte ce matin de suspendre
l'opération commerciale leclerc se dit
prêt à faire la même chose si les
magasins peuvent rouvrir le 28 novembre
comme le réclament les commerces
indépendants pour le nomme mal-être
ras-le-bol stress anxiété des primes
l'impact psychologique de l'épidémie et
plus encore du confinement est réel si
les commerces tous les autres commerces
n'ouvrent pas le 28 novembre d'abord ça
sera un bain de sang sur le plan des
faillites etc
et puis je pense que la colère des
expressions devienne une révolte la
santé mentale des français c'est ainsi
significativement dégradée entre fin
septembre et début novembre avec une
augmentation conséquente des syndromes
dépressifs observée pour tous les
profils socio démographiques
alors on vous épargne la suite et on a
adoré cet échange que si on le sort de
son contexte assure troy davis comme
d'autres distributeurs en france en
écoutant le les recommandations du
gouvernement nous avons décidé de
reporter la date du black friday
si cela permet de rouvrir les commerces
et les magasins physiques avant le 1er
décembre
parce que s'il ya bien une chose qui
n'est pas obligatoire dans la période
c'est bien d'être malheureux nous
vaincrons cette vague
nous vaincrons cette pandémie nous terra
seront ensemble ce virus donc cette
année le black friday aura lieu le 4
décembre
mais le résultat je vais bien
constatation n'est qu'à contacter
[Rires]